hello and welcome to this video playing
a national master who you I hate the
resistor okay wasn't maybe totally bad
but not the right pronunciation almost
for certain okay so got a 97 Moscow in
the Sicilian on oftentimes leading to
positions that look a lot like like a
ruler past
okay I don't don't get me to declare my
intentions there maybe I can usually I
just close that but why why not just
develop it's possible maybe the thing
that is a little bit off-putting here is
the Queen on e to after move like rookie
aide there could be pressure on the pole
and that looks weird
what does the Queen do won't be six okay
let's cover D form you know why do I say
it it looks weird because it kind of
it's kind of clear that Bishop III is
going to happen and then the Queen has
to move again if I now play Bishop III
there is nice G form so okay
yeah this book against Queen is a little
bit disconcerting but if he takes night
eggs okay yeah the C file might also be
problematic with Ruby see one coming but
I think now I should shut it down
actually and maybe it's got Knight b6 c4
Knight b6 to c4 was a little bit
worrisome it still is actually but ah
that's interesting
he's going for this regrouping okay
let's stop Knight see five at least
and Knight takes Queen III looks like a
very odd self pin so Queen Texas is
basically it's not forced but it's like
almost night eggs I don't see any upside
okay now yeah it's probably probably
roughly equal maybe I can do something
with a form it's more likely for me to
get an A for then for him to play a pawn
leave oh okay don't know exactly where
this is heading
Bishop Bishop aah is a hard move to make
ready but tough move to make as you
you're basically saying goodbye to your
bishop my boy okay so now I'm a four I
mean I don't really need it at the
moment you can double on the c4 I expect
him to play g6 and night h5 maybe okay
that's not a bad choice quickly doubling
on the C file I still have a little bit
of pressure though mostly due to that
really weird bishop only aid yeah I'm
happy to trade really so now how do we
do that a bishop this bishop has to be
activated and the best way to do that
would be value age three so I need to
cover let's cover this first and now I
probably need the King on e3 anyway so
let's start
h-hi okay so he tries to get this get be
should be seven and however if he plays
Bishop b7 I'm I'm ready to take on b5
yeah that winds like almost all of the
pawns so let's do it let's look at this
yeah tick I win so many pawns it's
really funny
okay now have seven you you cannot cover
so I'm going to save the H pawn
there is one issue I have I have too
many nights yeah you cannot checkmate
with two nights but he just resigned I
mean I'm having a five-point there for
the piece um so let's have a look at
this he went this early five and that
tried not to close down the center to
earlier so I cancelled first Bishop to
e7 that was all very standard looking
Knight c3 yeah it could be six surprised
me a little bit because I felt it just
steps into moves that I kind of want to
make anyway age three if he ate and now
I felt it's called for to close it down
like here and the engine at least thinks
it's a good move you know couldn't quite
figure out if I have something maybe we
look a c1 but okay let's do it Queen
went to be ATM this is a good move
Bishop d8 to be six Luke c1 bishop d8 I
want to play before in this position so
we should be 3s I think I think very
very natural before that stops night c5
and fixes the pawns on light squares
it's very much very normal no Mary
normal moves Queen d8 yeah now okay now
a4 yes that's absolutely true using this
opportunity and in fact um I thought
about it briefly but I didn't what I
didn't really see is that of course okay
night a4 should be a slight edge but
this is very strong going going to a5
similar to the game but here but Knight
to a5 Queen like a two takes on c4 and
absolute that's very nice very nice so I
played it
in a very slow way but I mean the bishop
is on it so that happened and now I
immediately went for the trades and here
I'm playing against the bishop
and if I get my Bishop to age three in
to activate it it should be nice I think
ultimately it came down to that trick I
mean why does of course for choice but
it's not like I'm winning or anything
but should be to dg3 it was clear that
there should be seven is is his
intention and therefore I played the
slowest move and yeah he fell into it
which is kind of understandable he had
no time left whether a little time left
if black plays some a better defensive
moves like Knight g8 not very intuitive
but like just don't play Bishop e7 then
you have certainly good chances to
defend I think white has an advantage
for sure but it's nothing too dramatic
but this is immediately getting killed
just winning winning all of the pawns
pretty pretty remarkable okay guys
thanks for watching